the Joe Rogan experience one day they're
gonna have an artificial body there's
gonna be a company that's gonna have an
artificial body that works perfectly and
they can guarantee that you can take
your brain out of artificial body and
put it in this put it in this new
perfect body take it out of yours put it
like a surrogate and they guarantee you
you'll live longer you get an extra
hundred and fifty years with Jewish your
body I'm a [ __ ] I would definitely do
it would you want to live forever no not
forever but nobody never know when to
end that's the thing there's like a
parable about that about some guy who
lives the hundreds of years but he has
to kill his kids in order to do it
I think Trueblood was kind of like that
to that movie when the [ __ ] was
them vampires he got tired of living
he's like is she born well I was in did
you imagine seeing people complain about
the same things for hundreds and
hundreds of years in they go against
fighting funny right the entire to this
[ __ ] then they go again but did you go
through the same [ __ ] every twenty years
yeah you probably get tired of killing
them two people that's 90 years old
Tyler here in this shitty with a view
though you just oh you know you just
laugh at the young people going through
this [ __ ] hey hey there you go did you
ever see interview with a vampire Oh
remember that Tom Cruise Brad Pitt movie
yeah but I was nice [ __ ] out watch it
the game it's a great [ __ ] movie but
the whole idea is that the part of it is
this these vampires been around for
hundreds of years and they're they're
starting to get sick of it mm-hmm it
kind of freaked out yeah that's not true
blue or the talus yeah makes sense
my grandma man she lied really yeah my
grandma from Bahamas she she be like
like she be depressing like she because
you got think about it when you that old
you only one around you're gonna go talk
to nobody give a [ __ ] your kids over
come over there to take cakes photo-op
see though I give a damn about this you
know so like if it's a true story she
she she passed out in the garage and
stayed there cuz she thought she was
dead and then she realized she wasn't
got up a walkway right back in the house
but you don't want to be here you
that's why you want something you would
even if you don't believe in God you
won't something after this like well you
like it gotta be something after this
year you I want it to me you would want
to think something after this because
this is this this is boring at the end
it's don't end good
it doesn't Unger see some people think
that for sure nothing happens and that
to me is just as dumb as thinking for
sure something happens you know either
way I'd rather be I really be right than
wrong she she never believed me like no
you ain't believe as I believe when you
see a dead person it seems like
something's gone I swear to God
with my bit when one of my best friend
the comedian that they passed that I
rest when that's like oh no this fear
has got to be a guard or something cuz I
saw it like this you feel they're gone
that you know when I was in the room
with him right on his deathbed I saw
like you could just see and you can see
that they see it cuz he really liked at
the time he wanted me he asked me play
smile [ __ ] for him and I played the
form and then after that he tried to
pull the thing out his mouth
and the fun thing about I didn't think
it was like nose is it I didn't see it
that's no suicide thing it was just like
you could see that he saw I next level I
mean next step
mmm you get what I'm saying and so that
I didn't let him do it the figures I
didn't want to see it I know them pulled
them down and told his sister to come in
but it's just you really see it being
when you're in there and you see life
and see it where ends and then you know
it's not a bad thing you just see like
this is this is what it is yeah this was
yeah it comes and goes comes and goes
that me and there's some some mix I hope
you know what someone said once and one
of the one of the Gracey fathers talked
about this too said he believed and he
lived his life
illy Oh Gracie lived his life like you
have to get everything perfect you have
to do everything the right way or you
come back and you do it all over again
yeah that's how karma that's our people
in Indonesia thing and there's no crime
over there when I was at in Bali
well it's great way to think it's right
way to think and if it's right I mean
maybe that's good think about even if
even if it ain't right you should think
that way
because if you thought that way and you
thought you come back looking like an
ant you ain't gonna be doing too much
crazy [ __ ] you're gonna do right you
will do right by people yeah that's what
UK well that always makes me think like
someone like you like how many times you
done this ride you don't mean like maybe
some people just maybe they don't
amongst us or just they're just new on
the ride that's what you know what times
that's the best way to articulate it cuz
it's like to me my whole life it like
this [ __ ] is so simple but to everybody
else is so complicated like maybe you've
been on the ride a lot maybe even on
this ride like a thousand times
that's crazy if it's real and look how
many times you think you've been on this
[ __ ] anyone think but life makes none
of it makes any sense it doesn't make
any sense if you and I are making noises
with our mouth and we both know what
we're saying and we're laugh and we just
met having a great time smoking weed
together talk [ __ ] that doesn't make
sense either like life is bizarre so if
life this way this this way that we live
which is really interesting if this goes
on forever like I enjoy life and I know
you do right enjoy it's great but if you
told me that was gonna go on forever
I'd go [ __ ] like this just goes on
forever and ever that's up here that's
gonna give me anxiety so is that so say
nothing then just let the spirit but if
it happens again and again and again
again and again and again throughout
eternity if that's what life is if you
just live this life over and over again
why would that be scary but it would it
be scary because if maybe I enjoy this
life but I want to think that there's
something better but if it's just this
life over and over and over again I get
it right why is that scarier than doing
it once because it's not scary to do it
once like right once like right now
I'm gonna have a great time you're
having a great time
he's having a great time we're having
fun right why wouldn't want to keep
doing this but if I knew that it was
gonna happen over and over and over
again forever I'd probably freak the
[ __ ] out but that might be what life is
[Applause]